kim kardashian is clapping back once
again
this time at rumors that she once hooked
up with travis barker
i actually didn't on wednesday the
reality star responded to claims made by
travis's ex-wife shayna moekler to us
weekly
alleging that kim had something to do
with the end of her four-year marriage
to travis barker
who is currently dating kim's sister
kourtney kardashian
kim shut down the rumors while she said
she was getting her nails done
doing a q a on instagram when a fan
asked about the allegations
she responded writing no false narrative
we've been friends for years and i'm so
happy for him in court
i love that as for what courtney and
travis are thinking about the situation
well a source tells e.t not much
the source says that travis courtney and
kim are completely unfazed by shayna's
claims
saying quote travis is so not kim's type
and travis has been in love with
courtney for so long
even when they were just friends they
think shayna just feels burned by her
ex and is saying things out of spite
bible
but when shayna spoke with e.t back in
march she insisted that she just wants
the best for her ex and his new
girlfriend
travis and i haven't been together for
almost a decade and
um you know we co-parent together we're
friends
however um you know i don't know
anything about his personal life like
that we're not
um as close like that anymore you know i
mean it's been 10 years he has his own
world going on i kind of have my own
world
um do i want him to be happy absolutely
i want him to
um i want him to be happy and you know
she makes him happy i think that's
awesome
and although kim may have had time to
clap back at those rumors
she's still seemingly struggling to
balance her schedule that is hard for me
if you do law school the way that i'm
doing it it is a four-year program
instead of your typical three-year
program and after year one
you have to take the baby bar this one
actually
is harder i hear than the official bar
you needed a 560 you go to 474
kim reveals on keeping up with the
kardashians that she did not pass her
first year law school exam
the fact that i spent all that time away
from my kids like i can't do it again i
don't have time
to do the next test is in november
november's in one month
i know and i'm filming the ending of our
show which will be so emotional
right oh my gosh i have every birthday
under the sun
and although kim feels discouraged about
the timing she reveals in her instagram
q a that she's going to pick up where
she left off
when a fan asked how the exams are going
she responded
extremely difficult unfortunately i
haven't passed yet but i'm not giving up
and i'm preparing to take it again
soon i'm not ready to stop it's a
sentiment kim shared with et in 2016
that she doesn't plan on slowing down
i think i put pressure on myself which i
i love that
um that energy in my life i don't i like
always being busy when i'm not
busy that's when i start to get
uncomfortable
you